daily wire and Candace Owens have ended
their relationship thank everybody who
has been on this journey with me people
that have supported me I especially want
to thank all of the Jewish people that
have been in the comments saying how
outraged they are and I know that it is
especially difficult for you guys right
now Candace Owens has been fired why
because she is talking objectively about
what's going on in
Gaza brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give 1010 in
donation and that1 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing de that you want to do but we
turn it into a moneymaking machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope Ramadan is going phenomenal
for you guys Candace Owens Candace Owens
used to work for the daily wire and
daily wire is owned by an absolute
scumbag dirt bag intellectual fraud
intellectual uh that he's uh
being finished many times by Muhammad
hijab when Muhammad's name is mentioned
he gulps out of fear he is a coward
desist supporter the supporter of the
IDF who are massacring men women and
children and the whole world has seen
their reality and we was thinking how
long is this going to last of course not
the freedom of speech Advocates where
are you guys gone the freedom of speech
Advocates where are you guys gone okay
what happened what happened even we just
heard that in King's cross a Hadith that
just mentions about people to have hope
in their self and the best of those who
sin are repent who repent King's cross
has taken it down what happened guys I
thought it was about freedom of speech
GB news what's going on I thought you
were against Council culture about you
know those to stop freedom of speech oh
it's only if it's Muslims Candace Owens
has been fired why because she is
talking objectively about what's going
on in Gaza uh news breaks this morning
from the daily wire CEO Jeremy boring he
tweets quote daily wire and Candace
Owens have ended their relationship so
this comes after a lot of internal
consternation between Candace Owens and
the US they put out an article stating
quote white supremacist and Holocaust
Den Nick Fuentes is praising Candace
Owens quote vitriolic anti-Semitism it
is hardly surprising but it does set off
alarm Bells when bigoted people come
together to push anti agenda it adds
fuel to the fire so Candace replied to
this she says I do not know MN quentes
you already know that what I do know is
that everyone can see what you guys are
doing to me your pattern is well
established and the world is waking up
against it my crime is having stood up
for myself against your network of
smears now Candace has particularly come
under major fire since October 7 from a
lot of these major conservative Media or
lot of these conservative organizations
or organizations like the ADL like APAC
like the Republican Jewish Coalition and
others they've attacked her relentlessly
she has not given in in fact has only
escalated some of the things that she's
talking about this has led to some major
debates on her channel for example with
rabbis leading to some frankly wild
discussions around what exactly
constitutes antisemitism and doesn't but
most importantly we actually have a clip
here that we can play from her very last
daily wire appearance she says at the
end I'll see you tomorrow and she hints
at the fact that some of the uh
consternation that she's kind of
bubbling to the surface let's take a
listen thank everybody who has been on
this journey with me people that have
supported me I especially want to thank
all of the Jewish people that have been
in the comments saying how outraged they
are and I know that it is especially
difficult for you guys right now because
you are being smeared you know I mean
I'm I'm not going to go away I'm going
to use my god-given voice to talk about
things are important for me I'm just
asking to be left alone or at least just
report the truth ladies and gentlemen
unfortunately that is all the time we
have for today but don't worry because
we'll see you tomorrow for a brand new
episode and even then she was like
careful to some stuff she says but still
not good enough like some IDF or some uh
pro-israeli spokesperson say which is
what if you're objective in your news
you are pro Hamas you cannot make this
up so you can see brother and sister
Subhan Allah my daughter's in the
background screaming crying but what you
can see is this guys yeah they do not
care about freedom of speech it is a big
lie a big fat lie and we witness mm when
we went to the Tommy Robinson freedom of
speech event when we got attacked and
nearly killed by these thugs this shows
you they do not care about freedom of
speech it is just a mask it's just this
false Banner they do not care about it
guys okay what they care about brother
and sisters is supremacy yes they just
care about their voice so much so that
they are sharing they are so much so
brother sisters that they are forcing
other countries to adop adopt lgbqt
yes and if you don't they are
sanctioning them you cannot make this up
guys Subhan Allah and Candace Owens has
been vocal many many times and we salute
her we salute her for being consistent
just the way the people like inside Tomy
Robin's Camp who were consistent and
exposed him that he does not believe in
freedom of speech so cace Owens cace
Owens you have got my respect I was
doubtful about you still but I thought
to myself you know what now that you've
lost your um your job at the daily
that's the best thing that's ever
happened to you cuzz these people do not
care about truth they just want a big
fat lie to be told and if anybody speaks
against it they will expose them that's
all I'm going to say inallah brothers
and sisters may Allah subh guide
kindless Owens to Islam where the truth
really relies alhamdulillah and once
again their face mask their mask has
dropped they do not believe in freedom
of speech brother and sisters do not
forget to donate to the link brother and
sisters below and help us to help our
brothers in
Gaza get